she has been to all 50 states
and i think that is really really
awesome so everyone please welcome
caitlin
awesome
thank you so much for having me um i'm
caitlin huden an r enthusiast and
principal data scientist at online med
ed which is an adult learning company
headquartered in austin texas
one of my favorite things about doing
data science is being uniquely empowered
to solve big business problems using
data
lately i've been focused on churn and
today we'll use my recent work to talk
through strategies for creating
impactful
analysis projects and how to execute
them
another one of my favorite things about
doing data science is exploratory data
analysis which i think is an unsung hero
of our field and so i'm really excited
to talk about how and why to turn
exploratory data analysis into formal
deliverables
before we get into data let's talk about
churn
so a very general definition is that if
a customer stops using your product or
service they are considered churned
churn is a big area of focus for
businesses and it's not hard to see why
if you can keep customers happier and
engaged for longer periods of time that
translates directly from retention into
dollars
data can be directly impactful on the
bottom line here so if you can
understand churn you can work to improve
your product and processes to make
customers happier and to reduce churn if
you can predict who might churn you can
proactively work to retain them
so for the project that i mentioned
earlier
i've been focused on understanding how
our customers interact with our platform
and how that usage relates to churn what
you see here is my project charter and
so
this is a dock that outlines the scope
the goals and the details of this
particular project
online meded is an adult learning
platform with a subscription-based
business model and like many
subscription-based businesses we start
with a trial
our trial is pretty important because it
serves as the main gateway into our
subscription business and so trials are
where users are most likely to start on
our platform
my goal as a data scientist is to
understand what happens during trials
including where customers seem to be
finding value or not and how trial usage
relates to churn or retention at the end
of the trial period
if there are areas where we can improve
the user experience or the platform i
want to uncover them so that we can be
more valuable to our users
here's one more slide from the charter
so one thing you might notice in the
deliverable section is that i'm not
promising a machine learning model or at
least i'm not promising one quite yet
this project hinges on a number of
exploratory analyses guided by
hypotheses that i've generated with the
help on a team so this is a project
firmly centered on exploratory data
analysis
the goal is understanding and
communicating what i learn in the
process and the deliverables reflect
that so i'm going to give specific
recommendations and a large presentation
so that people across the company can
build intuition for user behavior within
trials and then make improvements based
on what we've learned
predicting trial churn is a next logical
step but is specifically called out as
out of scope for this project so this
project is meant to lay the foundation
for the model and the final deliverable
will be the data set that we can use to
build the model
i mentioned that this project centers on
exploratory data analysis or eda and so
for anyone who's not familiar it's worth
explaining a bit about eda
i really like this definition from the
book r4 data science which is available
free online for anyone who hasn't had
the chance to read it yet um i highly
recommend that book
eda is basically the scientific method
distilled and so it's highly iterative
because at each cycle you provide new
insights and it gives you new
opportunities to refine your question
pull more data as needed and learn
things to fuel the next cycle
of understanding
eda is an important process for
understanding your data generally but
it's absolutely necessary if you plan to
build any machine learning models based
on your data
poking and prodding during eda is where
you find the holes and the weird
outliers and the quirks and the
limitations of your data and it gives
you an opportunity to improve the data
before you start to build with it
like brendan i've never once been burned
by understanding my data better but i've
absolutely been burned by building a
model before i fully understood my data
so i cut my teeth in data by helping
other people build predictive models and
some of my earliest models almost 10
years ago were churn models
one of the most valuable things i
learned during my time consulting is
that the value of a model extends beyond
its predictions so when we would show
clients the outcome of a model like
scores personalized at an individual
level
the first question inevitably that they
ask is how does the model work what's in
it
people want to understand what's
important and what's not for making
predictions and to check the model's
understanding against their own and i
can't overstate how important eda is
here
so most of the time when i'm building a
model i'm the first person to explore
that particular data set at the level of
depth required to build the model
this makes me the de facto expert the
most knowledgeable person in my company
about that particular set of data and
the analyst learns a lot during the eda
process those insights are generally
useful beyond what they may or may not
add to a model outcome
these insights are like cocktail party
anecdote levels of interesting for the
people whose domain they're in so like
marketers love to know what channels
stick out
product managers love hearing about
weird user behaviors and finance can
mine a lot of value out of the quirks of
high value users
in short sharing the insights generated
during eda is very important and that's
why i focused on making them into formal
deliverables
so how do we figure out what kinds of
insights from eda would be most useful
for other people in our org we talk to
people when i kicked off my project the
first thing i did after getting approval
wasn't to jump into pulling data
together for analysis although i had a
lot of fun doing that
instead i started by conducting 14
interviews with people across my company
to leverage their subject matter
expertise and build a more holistic
understanding of trials
i've listed several reasons for
interviewing smes but what i want to
focus on is
the middle one um i'm going to the store
do you need anything this is kind of how
i phrased my exploratory data analysis
and the types of insights that i could
pull from people i'm going to be working
with this data set for a while if
there's anything that i could do just
like one extra slice or one extra field
i could bring in that would make a big
difference for my coworkers and their
understandings and their ability to make
really good data informed decisions i
want to do that this is an opportunity
to do that and so um i made some friends
in the process getting to talk to people
about what they knew about trials and i
learned a ton before i was ready to
actually start analyzing the data
um i'm sharing a lot of actual artifacts
from this project and so these are the
actual interview questions that i asked
when i conducted those interviews
i started by walking through the project
charter which included the goals of the
project and a preliminary list of
hypotheses that i planned to explore and
then report back on
and when i was designing these questions
i had end goals in mind so i wanted to
understand as much as i could about
trials including bright spots pain
points areas to focus on but i was also
thinking about the data and how to make
the project as impactful as it could be
asking about changes in strategy and
approach is a really good way to suss
out inflection points in the data so for
example if like a particular pricing
strategy or marketing strategy didn't
work out it was a dud after a month or
so you might want to flag that data you
might want to have an awareness of that
because those patterns could be weird
when you start to dig in
and so the most important question on
this list to me is actually the second
to last one what specific
recommendations as a result of this
project would be most valuable for you
and your department so i straight up
just ask like what is useful what could
i deliver from this project that would
be super valuable for you
and then i took that information and i
tried to make a plan to incorporate it
into my analysis wherever possible
i started with a list of hypotheses to
guide my interview conversations and
then help frame the project so after the
interviews i circled back to the list
and refined the hypotheses to
incorporate all of the new information
that i gathered and what you see here is
a list of about half of the hypotheses
covered by this project
so these questions are going to guide my
exploratory data analysis if you think
back to the eda process the first step
is to generate questions
about your data and so now i have a list
of high value questions that i'll be
able to answer through eda which i've
refined through communication across my
organization
at this point i have a really solid
project plan so i know exactly the types
of insights i'm looking for i know a bit
about what data i should be pulling and
what i should be looking for there and
i'm ready to get started
i think it's really tempting at this
point to go completely off the map once
you have your marching orders especially
for a big project with company-wide
impact you want to make sure that you
get everything right before sharing your
findings you want to do the best job you
want to nerd out on the data a little
bit
uh but avoiding that instinct and coming
up with a plan to share your work is
super important here and so we'll talk
about how to get buy-in at the end of
this presentation but once you have it
it's important that you keep it by
delivering on what you promise and i
find that accountability is the opposite
of this black hole so frequent check-ins
help me to keep big projects like this
on track especially in my role as
principal there are always other
important projects that i could be
dedicated to
doing so much pre-work and scaffolding
for big projects like this gives me the
legs to stand on when data sirens start
calling and so it's much easier to say
no when i have a solid project plan that
i can point people to
for delivering value across the
organization
so instead of the black hole approach
i suggest that we approach sharing
insights from analysis in the same way
that software developers approach
releasing features iteratively by aiming
for continuous delivery
this is an example of what that might
look like for a project like this and
the kinds of value that you can get out
of continuously delivering insights so
in the first stage the research stage
i've done interviews um so deliverables
there the individual interview
transcripts are really interesting
that's telling me what people across
departments know and care about when it
comes to trials
and then another deliverable you can
make out of those is summarizing those
interviews it's really easy but getting
a cross cut of like 14 different
opinions on bright spots and pain points
of trials is actually a really valuable
business asset
when i get to data wrangling there's all
kinds of stuff you find at this stage
and so for me i think i pulled together
like 120 something
variables from 20 different data sets it
was a lot of data that had never been
wrangled in that way before so
everything that i was looking at was
brand new and we had a ton of stuff to
learn from it
so some of that stuff needed to be
productionalized taking that data and
putting together a more formal pipeline
so that we can use it for other analyses
or use it when we're getting ready to
build that model that's something i
could deliver
data collection gaps so finding and
filling data collection or process gaps
is another useful deliverable
eda insights so i'm kind of delivering
those piecemeal as i'm in the analysis
project or process
new metrics to track so sometimes you'll
find something interesting and you might
want to start tracking that over time
like this one quirk of the data tells
you a lot about churn and so it's a
metric that we maybe want to put on a
dashboard somewhere and so i could
communicate those to our bi team and
have them start tracking them
and then specific business
recommendations so i'm trying to make
recommendations
and if i can deliver those iteratively
i'm getting feedback on them i have the
chance to make
impacts while i'm actually still working
on the project and people can see the
value that i'm delivering over and over
and over again at different points
throughout this process
another really nice thing about
continuous delivery of insights is that
it gives you all of these pivot points
and check-in points to improve the
project so if you just go start
with the project charter and then end
with everything you're delivering it all
at once with no insight from anyone
along the way you're missing out on all
of these places where you could be
getting feedback and so it's the idea of
working in public but doing that within
your company and so for example
after the summary of interviews i found
new things that were important to look
at and so i restructured some of the
hypotheses so that i could incorporate
those findings
when i was looking at data collection
and gaps i found pieces of data that i
couldn't use that i planned to and
that's fine that actually gave me an
opportunity to fix them communicating
that right away means that by the time
we're ready to build that model we'll
have that data and that will be awesome
whereas if we waited until the end of
this project then we would have to wait
even longer for that data to trickle in
eda insights as i was working through
some of the hypotheses i would end up
going back and changing hypotheses to
come because i would find new insights
that informed
whether those analyses would continue to
be valuable
and then specific business
recommendations we're going to walk
through an example of one of these
hypothesis explorations and it's around
the length of our trial so we went from
a 30-day trial to a seven-day trial as a
result of one of my analyses and that
specific business recommendation had big
impact during the time period that i was
working on this and informs my work
going down the pipe and so continuously
delivering insights gives more
opportunities for feedback and results
in a better analysis i highly recommend
it
so the way that you can do that is to
build deliverable assets as you learn
the interview transcripts and summaries
we've talked about
one key piece here for me has been
taking eda insights and packaging them
into something that i can share with
other people so that that knowledge
doesn't just end with me
and then a new data set for machine
learning so that's kind of the end goal
here but really we're developing all of
the understanding and the insight around
this data before we get to that
so one thing that you can include in an
eda deliverable is visualizations i love
klaus wilkie's book the fundamentals of
data visualization can't recommend it
enough it's free online and he also has
code available that you can use to make
your own visualizations so just the way
that jesse mazda pack will share code on
twitter
to get you started with the database and
then you make it a lot prettier i've
taken some of the code that klaus wilkie
has shared and tuned it to my data in
order to share this stuff with
stakeholders and come up with some
really pretty
impactful data visualizations that help
people understand the relationships that
i'm uncovering and so this is one
example of a visualization that we
looked at
for people who used a specific product
that we have are they doing more or less
on the site and then we know when we're
ready to build a model like maybe we
want to um get some variables around
that also for product this is super
useful because then they know we need to
push people to this part of the product
this actually seems to make a difference
so there's lots of ways that those
insights could be useful to other people
beyond the model
another thing that we came up with is
the idea of this analysis summary card
and so
you can see on the left we have our
little logo for the dagger group so it's
very branded it's very clean and
polished and that's really important to
me so as i'm sharing results with other
people i want them to feel like we've
put a lot of effort into them they're
very clean and these are artifacts that
are going to live beyond this analysis
right i'm saving all of the work that
i'm doing so that people will understand
what analysis has been done how they can
apply it and what we've learned from it
and so here's an example of that
analysis summary card this is just
mocked up by our design team
see
um but this is an actual analysis
summary card that i shared
and so i looked into this hypothesis of
trial users are active for more than the
first week of the trial
and built this visualization to see
whether they're using different
modalities on our site and when i have
outcomes here i have key insights here
this is just one like
bite size deliverable that i can create
so people can understand the analysis
that i did the outcomes and get a visual
really quickly
and then i take this and i make a long
form write up
so i want people to be able to reference
what was my methodology who did i look
at where are these insights applicable
so i clipped some pieces here
i included things like key insights to
really call out the things that we are
learning as a result of this analysis
i'm also including a big business
questions and my recommendations vary
directly so in this case like the data
supported shortening the length of our
trial i had quantitative evidence for
that
as a bonus i have qualitative evidence
because of all of the interviews that i
did this is where this idea came up and
so i'm able to take all of that data
combine it and make better decisions as
a business and also still be prepping
for that predictive model
and then the final piece here is
distributing your findings and so once
you have them you want to make sure that
you're sharing them with other people
so we have a channel for this project
and whenever i finish part of it i go
ahead and just upload it to the channel
and people are able to read the long
form see the quick
one-shot
summary and then go from there and
that's been really helpful
making tailored recommendations for
impact has been something that's gotten
a lot of value out of this project
so i thought that we should change the
length of the trial and then the impact
you can see directly is this uh seven
day trial project so we kicked off
another project to take the insights and
just go with those build with those
um and so being able to quantify the
impact to trace it over time has been
really helpful and all of this again is
just kind of bonus more bang for the
buck that we're getting as we're on our
way to build a model and use this data
that we haven't used before
so when it comes to getting buy-in i'm
going to go pretty quickly through this
section i know i have like a minute um
starts with an idea
this didn't come from someone telling me
hey go solve churn this actually came
because i saw that there were users
using our product
who um were paying us or who were paying
us and not using it and that seemed wild
and so um i took that idea thought more
about it eventually thought it'd be
worthwhile weighing out the opportunity
cost of those ideas is very important
you want to make sure that you're
spending your time on the most important
things
getting feedback from other people
seeing again where this could help this
is building momentum for your project
if you can quantify impact i talk with
finance to see if we made you know a 10
change here how much does that mean in
terms of dollars and that makes it
easier to present
and then finally coming up with a
project proposal
these are the pieces of my project
proposal so it has like an overview
pre-work or research that i need to do
the hypotheses i want to explore
deliverables how long i think it will
take and a pre-mortem things that i
think could go wrong how would this
project fail all of this makes me super
prepared to get buy-in for this project
and then also when i'm ready to get
started all the pre-work is done i know
what kind of analysis i need to be doing
i know how to structure it i know who
cares about what it just makes things a
lot easier to get these kinds of
projects off the ground
thank you so much for having me
thank you very much that was wonderful
so before we get into our next speaker